at queen tex this is anything but
business as usual the company which
provides clothing and blankets to
Garza's health sector had largely
switched from manufacturing to importing
what it could get through the Israeli
and Egyptian blockade but now it's
rehiring laid off employees to make just
one product medical grade coveralls
the health workers preparing to confront
the coronavirus now we're getting an
income we can buy food for our children
and get them what they need before the
coronavirus we could just get a bit of
seasonal work co-owner Hassan l1 is for
now at least rare in Gaza someone who's
seen the effects of the pandemic up
close he'd been living in China for 15
years sourcing the company's products
when the virus started to spread
he was quarantined there for two weeks
before deciding to come home I knew the
virus would reach us here I wanted to
import the suit from China but it would
have taken too long so I got all the
specifications from Chinese friends and
decided to produce it here we found the
raw materials and made a prototype and I
got the Ministry of Health's approval he
says his five factories can produce a
thousand suits a day but goss's market
has only enough raw material to make a
total of 10,000 the same blockade that
has hampered the market has also slowed
the entry of the virus into Gaza but
with a handful of cases now detected
there is huge concern about the
potential impact on a densely packed
strip of 2 million people
reliant on an already struggling Health
System another textile factory and more
intense activity here and in four other
restarted sister factories they're
working two shifts a day to meet demand
but these masks aren't for Gaza they're
going to the occupied West Bank and to
Israel in the past Gaza factories had
been working around the clock to supply
Israeli West Bank and Gaza markets but
because of the Israeli siege we all
stopped our production lines since the
spread of the corona virus I got
purchasing orders from an Israeli
private company and another company in
Hebron in the West Bank a total of five
million masks
haboob has rehired more than a hundred
and fifty unemployed workers to fulfill
the massive orders but while he and his
employees are glad of this sudden surge
in demand there's also a fear that it
could be the prelude to a devastating
new crisis for Garza's economy and the
health of its people Harry Forsyth
al-jazeera